we're gonna begin with the news though
breaking news overnight major results in
an election with national implications
CBS News can now project that Democrat
Katie Hobbs will be the next governor of
Arizona defeating Republican Kerry Lake
a favorite of former president Trump
it'll be the first time that Arizona has
had a Democratic governor and two
Democratic senators since January of
1951. Christina raffini is following all
of it for us from Arizona for seeing a
major results here good morning
Good morning Tony well lake had said she
would accept the results of the election
if in her words voting was fair honest
and transparent but in a tweet after
multiple news organizations projected
her loss Lake said quote arizonans know
BS when they see it as the vote count
continued throughout the week late
complained without evidence that Arizona
officials had botched and slow rolled
the results an accusation the Republican
elections Chief in Maricopa County
called offensive now Lake needed a
strong showing with Lake counted ballots
in highly populated counties like
Maricopa but the numbers favored Hobbs
under Arizona law a recount is triggered
when a candidate loses by half a
percentage point or less at this point
it looks like Lake will not meet that
threshold Lake now joins the growing
list of trump endorsed candidates who
have lost their high profile contests
including other governorships in
Pennsylvania and Michigan this election
was closely watched not just because
Lake was running on an election denying
trump-inspired Playbook book but because
the governor of Arizona can of course be
the final check on the presidential
election process in the state
all right Christina you're in California
in fact not Arizona you moved on to
where they are still counting ballots
there in some key house races what's the
latest
still counting yeah the outcome of the
uncalled races here are going to help
decide this election at this hour CBS
News is projecting the GOP is only two
seats away from taking control of the
house Democrats are at 211 seats to
Republicans 216. now remember 218 is
that magic number they need to clinch
and the Republican party is seeing some
success in what had been traditionally
blue States like here in California and
New York now if the Republicans win
control it will only be with a narrow
margin and while current House minority
leader Kevin McCarthy has launched his
bid to be speaker he may face challenges
from the most conservative wing of his
party
all right we'll be following it
Christina thank you very much